I am probably the biggest Shania Twain
like freak i slayed in that leopard
outfit I actually took it home literally
moments before I found out that I was
actually going on lip sync battle Shania
Twain DM to me because on my insta
stories I sing all the time and I'd like
to really weird close-ups and I'm always
like I'm going out tonight
and she goes let's go girl with the
dancing emoji Ashley is in Toronto today
celebrating the launch of a milestone
collection with Edition out the thing
that I'm so excited about Purple Rain is
that you can really see the evolution of
where we started with my collection 15
collections ago alongside our new
lingerie line Ashley has a talk show in
the works and possibly a second book the
body positivity activists wrote her
first memoir a new model and just
wrapped up her book tour one of the most
amazing and humbling experiences that
I've had on this whole book tour is the
young girls who just literally cry in my
arms because it really goes to show that
where people are hurting but people are
also rejoicing in the fact that we are
in this huge body revolution